ron rivera is going to meet with the
media today for his camp opening press
conference i thought it was unusual and
it is unusual
the team is restricting access only to
those who cover the team on a daily
basis no national sports media no news
media gives ron rivera a way to avoid a
lot of questions that he probably would
not like to talk about on monday he
spoke to ben standig who covers the
washington football team for the
athletic and
ron rivera had kind of a unique request
he said ben it's guys like you and other
local reporters that could help us write
all the bad articles now get all the
past out of the way but as we start
going forward write about where we are
and where we're going help pushes
forward that's my message that i'm
trying to tell everybody i get it there
are some things that were totally effed
up but let's stop telling everybody that
everything's f'ed up and start saying to
everybody hey look what they're trying
to do look how they're trying to fix it
now i love ron rivera as a coach i have
as much respect for him as i have for
any coach in the nfl and maybe more
but
some of these guys just don't get how
the media works you don't get to ask or
tell or expect how a team is going to be
covered and you could say yeah you know
he's kind of joking around
when you combine those comments with the
fact that they are keeping
everyone out of today's press conference
it's a virtual press conference but you
have to be local media who cover the
team on a daily basis to get in they're
trying to show
that we're only going to give you access
and we expect something from you in
return we want you the people who cover
the team on a daily basis to cover the
team in a certain way and you know what
if you don't it's going to be a problem
i feel like that's the message that's
coming from the franchise as they try to
turn around this horrible coverage
they've they've had
and they've deserved to have chris yeah
well they definitely deserve it there's
no doubt about it i don't look at it you
know certainly from not the ron rivera's
standpoint like he's trying to like hey
you know you do we'll do you a solid you
do us a solid i don't i don't look at it
totally that way now maybe it's implied
well i think somebody but all i'm saying
is i don't think it's ron rivera doing
that now maybe dan snyder and some other
think tank guys above him in the
organization that's their reasoning and
maybe ron rivera is maybe a little
reluctant because he's like man i don't
want to get into you know just politics
and racism talk you know all day here
when i'm trying to go coach a football
team i think more though just from him
alone it just to me it sounds like he's
he's trying to change the mantra and the
aura around the team and and and really
change the conversation you know i like
you said you're a fan of him i know i am
too i mean he's he's a very easy person
to like he's very respectful calm well
thought out you know uh you know you
could tell he's a caring person when
you're around him i mean he tried when i
was trying to get into coaching he
really you know said some nice things to
me and and you know gave me his number
and opened the door for a conversation
and hey i'll see if i can do anything
for you there so that's where i've
gotten to know him a little and you know
i just think from that you know from
what he's dealing with right now it's
not it's not easy but he is the right
guy to kind of get things straight on a
humane level and to straighten out the
football team and i you know again he's
in a very tough spot here so i don't i
don't think he's trying to play politics
here i think he's just trying to kind of
change the message and go hey this is a
new era here in washington we're
changing things we're working on it we
know we were effed up he's taking that
head on and he's going he's letting you
know that he's doing his best to kind of
change what's going on there
and i'm fine with that if he stops short
of basically recruiting the local media
during an on-the-record interview to
help in the effort to cover the team in
a way that pushes the negativity aside
because he doesn't want that negativity
filtering its way into any conversations
with players he doesn't want it
filtering into the locker room he wants
his players to focus on the future and
he wants the media who covers the team
to be on board with that and i'm always
sensitive to that chris because i think
what's happened over the past 10 or 15
years in sports i don't think it's
what's happened i know it's what's
happened as leagues hire people to cover
a sport as teams hire media members to
cover the team
they develop an expectation that even
the people who aren't getting a paycheck
signed by roger goodell or signed by
daniel snyder are going to behave that
way too and that's just wrong there
needs to be an independent press that
asks the questions that need to be asked
that serves as the conduit to the fans
and it doesn't just shake pom poms and
root for all the good stories and
overlook the negative stories that's why
that's why we we need to and a lot of
fans don't get that but you need to be
skeptical of that yes and and they're
part of the team almost
yeah and if you're and if you're being
paid by someone not daniel snyder to
cover the team it's not your obligation
to do what daniel snyder or ron rivera
want you to do and the problem is they
dangle access
right they dangle interviews right ben
standick now is going to be on board
because he got an exclusive with ron
rivera and it's going to be hard for him
to be critical of ryan rivera at least
in the short term because ron rivera
just did him a favor right ron rivera
gave him gave him the the the access and
and that's how the game gets i know how
that's the game get how that the game
gets played that way all the time
everywhere yeah but it just it had a
different edge to it here because he
articulated it he verbalized it and uh
we're just gonna have to see what
happens yeah no you're right we're gonna
have to see what happens and you know
hopefully the people that continue to
follow the team can be still fair about
the situation like you're right hey
listen a lot of local beat writers you
know they're they're worried about
challenging the challenging the team or
the coach or maybe some of the stars on
the team because yeah they're worried
that ultimately it'll affect their
access to oh i was supposed to get a
one-on-one sit down with this guy or
this coach or i used to get inside
information and now i've written a few
bad things about the team and nobody
gives me inside info anymore very real
thing uh there's no doubt about that
chris chris yeah from the moment from
the moment i started calling for the
name to change how many washington
interviews do you think i've got seven
years how many do you think oh you mean
you don't need a you don't need a hand
you don't need one hand to to to count
it's that few huh
yeah we got adrian peterson one time
through adrian peterson right we got
adrian peterson one time through adrian
peterson not through the team other than
that no one from washington well yeah i
know
that's how the game's played it is if
you make them mad they're not gonna give
you access there's no doubt about it you
know i know you're right hey listen i
i'm i'm experiencing it myself you know
sometimes when you're honest and things
like that all of a sudden you know oh
damn i thought i was supposed to get
that guy as a guest on my podcast uh he
doesn't want to come on because he heard
what you said three weeks ago whatever
it is you know okay great i don't know
damn be mad at me because i told the
truth all right i just you know you're
right and then you know the other thing
that always frustrates frustrates me
with that crap is when i say something
good about these people i never hear
like hey thanks for sticking up for me
or that was that was really nice yeah i
never hear that crap but uh either way
yes it's a it's a fine line and it's
certainly a little political
uh in the nfl right now and all angles
and and this certainly is is the case
here with with the media and this
washington name change and everything
else with it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports